what is up everybody you are not going
to believe what is happening in 2024 I
don't know if it's out just yet but
there is an article right now talking
about how prisoners can get artificial
intelligence injected into their mind so
that they can do their prison sentence
in not years but minutes so check it out
this is on NBC News it says new prison
concept could see inmates serve
sentences in minutes how they do that
what kind of techn ology are they doing
right here it says the cognify method
would see criminals hooked up to
high-tech machines that implant
artificial memories directly into their
brains this is like Ready Player One
stuff except in Ready Player one you
know you put the goggles on and you
enter into the world and it's because
that artificial world is so much better
than your you know poor existence of
life that life just got so terrible and
mundane and that you just entered into
this world and you can be whatever you
want to be and but now we're talking
about artificial intelligence implants
into your mind it says Inside the
subject's Mind time would pass
differently slower than in real life
making them experience years worth of
artificial memories in just a few
minutes so have you ever fallen asleep
and you're asleep for like a couple
minutes you just took a nap and you wake
up and you're like whoo I just had this
crazy dream like man it felt like it was
forever it was hours long and we were
doing all this stuff and somebody's like
man you were just asleep for like three
minutes because in your brain your brain
can just slow down time and you can have
all these crazy random thoughts thoughts
can just enter your mind at the speed of
light now technology has found a way to
manipulate that and say look uh you want
to serve your 30-year sentence in 30
minutes hey you have that option do you
just let us put artificial intelligence
into your brain and in 30 minutes you'll
be back on the streets but it'll feel
like you served 30 years we have to keep
talking about this depending on the
seriousness of the subject's crime and
their sentence the memories could be
tailored to the rehabilitation needs of
each subject and it's tailored you know
there's like some kind of uh
rehabilitation in there during your
sentence you could be being trained on
how to be a better person or something
in your mind in this artificial
intelligent world where it's only
minutes going by the complex Vivid and
lifelike memories are created in real
life using AI generated content this is
insanity the concept is the brainchild
of Dubai based Project Lead husham AI or
Al Gali and it says a
biotechnologist and science Communicator
once the target brain regions are
identified cognify I guess that's the
name of the software is then placed
around the head of the prisoner the
intensity of the and the type of
artificial memories are then adjusted
depending on the crime so I don't know
are they going to give you like
different forms of torture depending on
your crime or maybe you're behind prison
bars if it was really bad but in other
situations maybe you're on a deserted
island I don't know what's going to be
the cause of
how bad your sentence is going to be but
then it says synthetic memories are
customized depending on the crime
committed and the unique brain structure
and psychological profile of the
individual so this is where they're
talking about like if you got real
problems we're going to you're going to
go through Rehabilitation inside this AI
world the artificial memories implanted
by the cognify would be seamlessly
incorporated into the existing neural
networks of the brain preventing
cognitive dissonance and ensuring the
subject experiences the memories as if
they were real so they're not going to
be able to say no this this isn't real
that's what they're talking about
cognitive dissonance cognitive
dissonance is when something um you hear
a piece of information or see a piece of
information that you just can't compute
because it there's no way this can be
real like if you hear a uh the Earth is
flat or something you're like no
cognitive distance there's no way that's
possible because it just isn't this
software says there's no way to fight
this you will believe that this is
reality first The Prisoner is given a
choice either spending 10 years in a
prison cell or seeking Fast Track
abilitation through artificial memory
implantation it says artificial memories
could cover a wide range of crimes
including domestic violence hate crimes
discrimination embezzlement insider
trading theft and fraud violent
offenders could experience memories that
are designed to trigger empathy and
remorse seeing their crime from the
perspective of their victim and feeling
their pain and suffering firsthand so
they're basically going to put you in
some role play to where your the the
victim he's now experiencing the crime
that he did on somebody else now he gets
to it's like give them a taste of their
own
medicine some memories are designed to
trigger consequences and Trauma simulate
a long-term consequence of violent
actions such as the grief of the
victim's family or the S or the physical
and emotional trauma endured by the
victim after therapy it says in quotes
the subject is then released back into
society to start a new life away from
crimes the cognify concept could
revolutionize the criminal justice
system by significantly reducing the
need for long longterm incarceration and
its Associated costs by rehabilitating
so basically you know overpopulation of
of prison cells and the cost of taxpayer
dollars this is where they're thinking
that this could help but what are the
other negative implications of this by
rehabilitating the offenders more
quickly cognify could enable them to
reintegrate into society sooner and
contribute to the workforce but they're
talking about okay if you do this then
we could help not have overcrowded
prisons we wouldn't have to depend on
taxpayer dollars but what are the
negative implications of this imagine
some guy murders your wife or your
husband and he decides you know what I
want to take my sentence in minutes
instead of years so he does the 30
minutes or whatever it is even if it was
a whole day imagine seeing that murderer
who murdered your spouse on the streets
the very next day okay maybe it felt
like 30 to 50 years to him maybe he's
been really rehabilitated and he's a
different person when he comes out of
there maybe but what about the person
the victim when they see the person
literally walking on the streets like
nothing happened the very next day how
crazy is that but more importantly than
that more maybe not more importantly but
another crazy thing to think about is
they have the technology to do this they
have the technology to put artificial
intelligence into your brain and make
you believe that you are in another
world
for years when you've only been in there
in minutes think about
the evil that can be used with this
technology think about the evil that can
be done with this type of Technology
where maybe in the future like
Revelation talks about where all those
who keep the Commandments of God will be
punished persecuted in you know put in
prison and now we are forced to uh feel
like we've been
spending years upon years being set on
fire and and and it just goes on forever
and ever think about that because I
believe that Satan is using this
technology I believe that Satan is
trying to make a counterfeit Heaven a
counterfeit Paradise where people can
enter into this world they can put this
stuff on say hey you know what my life
is terrible I I don't have any friends I
don't have a spouse um I can't keep a
good job and they enter into this false
reality where they can be whoever they
want to be if they feel like if it's a
man that feels like a woman he can be an
avatar that's a woman he can be an
animal if he wants to be he can be
whatever he wants to and you can do
whatever you want to do this is what
Disney has been propagating and training
us up for years where they say I want to
take you to a world where there's no
rules Peter Pan flew up to Wendy's
window and he said I want to take you to
a world where the lost boys are where
there's no rules there's no parents it's
always about no rules the Bible talks
about lawlessness the Lawless one will
come and that's the spirit of antichrist
lawlessness imagine if they say look if
we live in this artificial intelligent
world we can do whatever we want and you
won't be hurting anyone else you know
these people these sick individuals who
uh I won't say the word but they have an
attraction to Children then they can act
out that sick fantasy in their
artificial intelligence world and no one
will be hurt or hey you know what
you're um a rapist will put you in this
world and you can do that as much as you
want and you won't hurt anybody this is
lawlessness the spirit of antichrist
where people can just enter in to
Satan's paradise and live their
wickedest
fantasies and what kind of a world is
that where we allow that to happen do
you think a person that's in that world
is ever going to receive Christ
basically their eternity is shut off at
that point they're never going to have
Christ because they're never even going
to be in a world where they can hear the
witness or go to church or bump into
somebody on the street that's going to
give them the word of God because guess
what AI is a very biased technology I've
asked AI to make certain things and it
will tell you it can't do it I've um
actually a friend of mine was trying to
make thumbnails and he said make a
graphic showing a person walking away
from the homosexual lifestyle and it
said I'm sorry I cannot make this image
this is hate speech and then he said
make an image of a person embracing the
homosexual lifestyle and it created this
beautiful image of somebody you know
coming out of the closet and and
embracing that lifestyle it is a very
biased technology and it
has uh it has controls on it that we
can't overcome so imagine if somebody
enters in that into that world you're
not going to hear the gospel you're not
going to hear you're not going to bump
into a pastor in that world no all it's
going to be is Babylon it's going to be
Sin City everywhere it's going to be
casinos prostitution whatever your
darkest desires and so when I was
thinking about this I was thinking about
living in a world where time goes by at
a different rate where minutes feel like
years and it made me think of the Book
of Revelation where it
says in Revelation 96 and it says in
those days men will seek death and will
not find it they will desire to die and
death will flee from them I can't even
imagine what that verse means I've tried
to think about that and I can only
imagine you know that people are there
they realize that they've rejected
Christ and he's coming and that's the
worst thought in the world but how can
you literally escape death I mean
anybody could kill themselves the Bible
talks about Saul falling upon his sword
and killing himself but what kind of
situation is it where men will seek
death and death will flee from them
maybe it could be something like this
type of Technology we're in 2024 and
we're talking about implanting
artificial intelligence false memories
into your brain to where
minutes feel like years this is insane
guys I believe we're in the last days
more and more every day I see this world
spinning out of control utter chaos
everywhere I just wanted to share this
information with you because I believe
that Jesus is coming soon I believe we
need to get ready you need to share this
information with others because there's
a lot of people out there that are just
going to be blindsided they don't even
realize how bad the world really is but
this type of Technology can be used for
the most extreme wickedness I can't even
really imagine what this type of
Technology could be used for I believe
that these prisoners are going to be
used as guinea pigs to see does this
technology work and they're going to be
tweaking it how can we use this for our
purposes if you like this video like it
please a like goes a long way it gets
this video out into the algorithm if
you're not a subscriber please click
subscribe there's going to be a lot more
videos like this coming out each week
and I just love you I ask for your
support and ask that you would just
take your relationship with Jesus
seriously I love you God bless